as we get closer day by day
to the much overdue removal of donald
trump
we have to start seriously addressing
the question of
how to deprogram nearly
75 million trumpists this is not a
trivial matter
this is not easy to do i've said before
trump will go
but the trumpists will still be here the
trump ism
that has become their sort of guiding i
don't want to say guiding principles
because they're it's not very principled
but
they're guiding ideology that will be
here so how do we do it how do we
deprogram
these people a retail strategy of
convincing individuals that their views
are misguided
is just too time time-consuming i had
this caller to my show last week who
said david
i did it i deprogrammed one trumpist and
i said yeah well
how long did it take and the guy said it
took three hours so as you can see
three hours times 75 million that's a
problem
all right it's easy and popular to say
education's the solution we have to
improve education well we do
but that's not going to help people
already out of school there's no doubt
that
teaching critical thinking media
literacy epistemology starting when kids
are 10 11 12
that would preemptively insulate a lot
of
americans from being brought into these
cult mentalities
but we're talking about 75 million
people mostly who are already out of
school so fixing education won't fix
them
so what do you do if you research cults
you very quickly learn that forcibly
removing people
is not recommended it rarely works you
need to get people to a place
where they choose to leave the cult
voluntarily
what we do know is that socratic methods
of questioning
asking people what attracted you to the
cult what was gone
going on in your life when you you know
you don't want to necessarily use the
word cult here but when when you
started to say hey i think trump has
something for me what was going on in
your life what attracted you to it
how would you know if the leader was
lying what would it mean to you
if you realized that the leader was
misleading you
how would you react that type of
socratic interviewing and questioning
can be useful but again we're talking
small scale cults here we are dealing
with 75 million people who are regularly
being
programmed by fox news and rush limbaugh
and the republican party and others and
they're being pulled further into the
cult
so it's not looking great so far one
idea
is that their beliefs and delusions have
to have
consequences that they link to their
beliefs and that last part is very key
obviously trump cultism has led to more
coronavirus deaths than we needed to
have
we have we are worse off as far as
health care goes our foreign policy is
is materially worse because of of
trumpism and the trump cult and trump
so there are consequences to trumpism
but your average cultist
will never link the consequences to
their cult leader in this case donald
trump
so one idea is actually seeing
and feeling the consequences of their
beliefs could be a start
but how do you do that how you do it
when we don't even have agreement
about the basic facts is a real problem
and
this as you can probably tell is such an
overwhelming herculean task
that it's likely going to require
multiple components and a sort of full
court press
approach so education yes more education
for young people
uh but that is going to deal with people
who are mostly not yet voters we need to
do something about
current cultists do you have to look at
the fcc
and look at what canon should be done
from a regulatory standpoint in terms of
media
yeah i guess so but i don't think you're
going to solve this problem
by banning fox news and you you run into
some real problems with regard to uh
suppression of speech when you do that
so i don't know how big of a part
that's going to play another big part of
this
is we need to make it less appealing to
be part of the cult
lots of people get drawn into cults and
conspiracy theories in the first place
because they either find the cults and
conspiracies better
than the alternative of the real world
or because people are isolated and they
get a feeling of belonging that's really
tough to pull people out of so
part of this is making it less seductive
to be part of the cult while recognizing
the underlying concerns that people have
and that's what trump
on purpose or accidentally this is what
trump did do well in 2016
by by tricking people trump bamboozled
people
by convincing them that he had the
solutions
to their problems a fear that a lot of
white voters had
of losing a privileged status in society
trump said he would take care of that
immigrants as the reason that you aren't
making more money trump said he would
fix it
so part of the deprogramming has to be
acknowledging
people's concerns but making them
realize that they've been sold the wrong
solutions
a really really important aspect of this
and even if we do all of this
we have to realize that change is slow
unless it's a completely authoritarian
dystopia
if you consider that the start of this
cult that we see today
could have been the welfare queen
stories of ronald reagan's presidency 35
years ago
and you understand that this has been 35
years in the making
it no longer is reasonable to think
we're going to get out of it very
quickly it's going to take time
if you consider the start of the current
republican cultism
to be the civil rights movement of the
1960s
then you know if it took 50 years to get
into this 60 years to get into this it's
going to take a while to get out
one of the faster deprogrammings we've
ever seen
or better said maybe reprogrammings was
in china
during the cultural revolution under mao
zedong
it was a roughly 10-year period the
leftovers of of capitalism were purged
and it was done brutally and quickly
and quickly still meant a decade so what
i want people to understand
is this isn't going to happen overnight
the fastest
reprogrammings have been brutal
and horrifying like the 10-year cultural
revolution in china
the path will be very long and it
typically requires the type of
commitment
that two four and six year political
terms which is what we see
in the house white house and senate two
four and six years
that's not a timeline that incentivizes
the difficult work that needs to be done
so send me your thoughts
send me your ideas this is going to be a
very very long fight which
it can start the day we decide it starts
i believe it has already started to some
degree
send me your thoughts i'm on twitter
deepakman
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a
massive holiday sale on all of their
products right now and you can take
advantage of it by going to
davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication to
the craft of watchmaking which is really
evident when you look closely at their
watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wrist watch from high-end
materials but one that
everyday people can afford and that's
why they have over
25 000 5 star reviews
because you won't find a better made
watch for
this great of a price anywhere else you
can get
big holiday discounts on all of their
products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video